This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn.
the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice in so much, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Mancini.
My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available.
I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWA percent on the IHeartRadio app, Apple podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say
that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s, and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world, it is so great to have you here back for another episode as we break down the psychology of our 20s. Today, we're going to talk about love. Love, meaning someone new, being obsessed with them is honestly one of the best feelings that I think
we can experience. There is something special about those early days that is just so exciting and addictive. It feels like the honeymoon period is going to last forever. And then obviously at some stage, real life kind of sets back in. Or for some of us, that initial craziness is really, really terrifying. It's really scary to feel like this person who we may love might actually be a source of fear for us, not because they are unsafe, but because what we are experiencing for the first time is healthy love. And that healthy love feels like boredom. It can cause us to call into question all of these different things, whether this person is actually right for us. And I really want to break that down today. And that big question of,
why does healthy love sometimes feel boring? And does this sense of boredom truly mean that this person is not right for you? Or is it just your relationship anxiety popping up at the worst time? We are joined by the brilliant Sarah Yudkin for this episode from You Love and You Learn. I'm so excited to have her on because she speaks so much about relationship anxiety and the ways that it gets in our way of finding really fulfilling. feeling love and relationship. So Sarah, welcome. Thank you so much for coming on to the podcast. Thank you for having me. I'm excited to talk about this. I feel like I can talk about it all day.
So buckle up. My goodness. I know. Well, it's so interesting because you listened to an episode that we did around relationship of anxiety with Katie and you were like, oh my goodness, this sounds exactly like what I talk about in my practice. And it's really not spoken about that much. I don't think I even really came across it until I got into my most recent relationship and was like, why is this suddenly so hard yet so easy? Like I feel like that is such a much more common experience than we know. Before I jump into it, though, I feel like I'm just jumping the gun. Are you able to like briefly introduce yourself? Tell us about who you are about your work. Yeah, of course. So I'm Sarah and I have.
help people who are in healthy, loving relationships. I always give that disclaimer right from the jump that we're not talking about abuse here, but I help people who are in healthy, loving relationships, but also who have anxiety that's holding them back. And the reason why I fell into this work is because my parents got a divorce actually when I was in my 20s. And at the time, I kind of stuffed it down and was like, it's okay. I get why they did it. They're better off. They're happier. And I thought that I didn't necessarily. care that much. I was like, it is what it is. But when I found myself in a very safe, loving relationship, I very quickly realized that the fear of divorce kind of was looming in the background.
And right when things started getting serious with now my fiance, but at the time, my boyfriend, I was like, what if I got a divorce? How do I know I'm not going to get a divorce? How do I pick the perfect person and make sure that he has no. red flags and that everything is exactly what I'm envisioning in order to make sure that this doesn't happen. And I realized that it did affect me a lot more than I thought at the time. And maybe I hadn't fully processed the fears around love and relationships. And so I just became so fascinated by it. And now I help others through their journey with that. Oh, my goodness. That's actually, congratulations on your engagement as well. That is so beautiful. Thank you. And I think
a story that is so much more commonplace than we think. Like, there are so many small things in our past, in our childhoods, even in our adolescence and our 20s that really shape how we approach and see love. And I think you can experience anxiety in any area of your life in which there is fear, any area of your life in which you have expectations or a false alarm. So can you kind of explain what relationship anxiety actually is? What kind of sets it apart from what we would typically see anxiety as being? Yeah, definitely. So my take is that there's kind of like a, I don't even like the word normal,
but I'm just going to use it here for this case. I think there's a normal amount of questions that could come up when you're committing to someone for the rest of your life. like, oh, is this someone I want to be with or, you know, kind of just like assessing the situation. Whereas relationship anxiety takes it up a notch to a whole other level. And a question such as, is my partner funny enough, can turn into a three week spiral because then it's not only are they funny enough, but oh my gosh, I'm never going to laugh in my life and I'm going to wake up one day and realize that I could have married this other person that was funnier. And so relationship
anxiety is doubt about your healthy relationship. And again, I say the word healthy because if you're having anxiety because you're being mistreated, then that's not what we're talking about here. But it's really taking up a notch the normal questioning or doubts that might come up in a relationship. And it can come in the form of physical symptoms, like your chest tightens, you have lurching stomach when you think about the future. You feel maybe like, warm or sweaty sometimes when you're trying to kind of sort out how to move forward in your relationship or it can come in the more mental symptoms like overthinking, waking up and kind of starting to initially ask questions about your relationship or getting home after spending time
with your partner and kind of fact-checking everything and having this microscope of was that fun enough, did I feel good enough, all of that. So that's a little bit more about it, but I'm happy to explain anything else as far as how it comes up to. It's really interesting because all of those, I don't know if they're symptoms, but all of those, let's just call them feelings or indicators of relationship anxiety, feel a lot like justified anxiety, feel a lot like, not so much justified anxiety, but justified fears, right? Like, I think the thing about anxiety of any form but particular relationship,
anxiety is that there is, it's very difficult to distinguish between, is this actually a real fear or is this a false alarm? And if I ignore what is a real fear, what are the consequences of that going to be? So I think that that hypervigilance also comes from like a place of like perfectionism as well, of like, I want to ensure that I make no mistakes when it comes to this, that I'm not overlooking anything that could potentially harm me. and then I think it comes down to inevitably what is self-sabotage, where because you are so hypervigilant over every single minute detail of your relationship, you don't actually give someone space to be imperfect or to be authentic
or to maybe do things that you don't totally love and adore, but which are part of like our quirks. Do you think that relationship anxiety causes us to self-sabotage a lot? Definitely. Definitely. And I want to circle back to one thing you just said, which is that it can be really hard to parse out what is your anxiety versus what is your fear. And I just want to remind people that love and relationships have a lot of risk associated with them. Right. So no matter how happy you are in the relationship or no matter how safe or no matter how steady the relationship is, we don't get guarantees, right? Like we don't know. what's going to happen in the future. And there's a lot of potential loss or, you know, people have fear of abandonment, fear of failure. Like, what does it mean if this doesn't work out? And I put all of this energy into it. What if I lose myself or sacrifice part of myself in this
relationship? There's so many fears that can come up. And so I just want to normalize the fact that if love, for whatever reason, feels scary or intimidating to you, that that is okay and that is valid and it's very understandable. And so to the point then about self-sabotage, if love hasn't felt safe to you because of maybe a relationship you had with a parent or a caretaker, or maybe it was seeing your parents split up or argue all the time or never argue and so you put pressure on yourself never to do that. Or maybe you had a past relationship that didn't work. Even a past friendship. Like there can be so many reasons why love hasn't felt safe to us. And then we compare our love with social media and seeing kind of like the perfectionism of that.
And so then we start to your point adding all of that perfectionism on top of the fear. And so it can be really hard to suss everything out. And that's why I think we end up unintentionally, of course, self-sabotaging because it feels overwhelming. It feels scary. It feels like we have to get it right. And so if there's any evidence that this isn't right, I'm getting the ick. this person clearly doesn't understand me, they're clearly not my soulmate, then we can put that block up and be like, well, they're clearly not it. So I might as well just kind of put this to a stop
and either behave in a way that they end it or I should just end. So you made a really good point about if you perhaps haven't had any good role models for what love maybe should look like, healthy love. And also if you've had like a sequence of terrible relationships that have taught you the version of love that you should not be aspiring to, right? People who have belittled you, people who have neglected you in some way, who have not treated you with respect, who have just been perhaps quite cruel or quite unaligned with who you are. After those experiences, I think we begin to question what love actually is and we get a little bit confused about what it looks like. How can we actually tell what healthy love is? How can we tell when it is actually safe?
It's a great question. And I feel like, you know, my answer might not be the only answer, right? Because love is such a vague concept. But I think when it comes to, especially moving away from an unhealthy love into a healthy love, what we're looking for is, feeling like both people or all the people involved can feel safe to be who they are and that there's doesn't have to be 100% equal but like both people are showing up and giving energy to the love and I think healthy love is about giving and receiving versus what can I get from this or only what can I give where you're not getting anything back and that's kind of like at a very fundamental level but I also think that love and this is a new belief that I had to form over the last few years that felt really helpful for me is that love
is not just a feeling love is a verb love is an action love is a practice and there's this really beautiful quote i believe it was from paolo cacchello who wrote the alchemist but he said something along the lines of like you can only find love through the act of loving and that feels really good to me because even if I'm not in a fully loving mood, I know I can act loving. And it doesn't mean that like you're necessarily pretending, but it's more of like taking the action towards someone you love or towards something you love and then kind of generating it versus just sitting there waiting for it to fall into your lap or waiting for your partner to bring you the flowers for you to feel love, if that makes sense. It makes so much sense because I do think that this is also a
belief that I've had, like, the older that I've gotten, which is that, like, it should be intentional, like, love should be intentional. The same way that you don't love your hobbies all the time, or you don't love your, like, passion all the time, there are going to be moments where you do need to actually be, like, an active player. And I think the reason why we treat love sometimes like that is because we're used to thinking of love as, like, this passive thing that we fall into, we think of love as this like outside emotion that comes to us and fills us up and that there's nothing we can really do to change that. I think it's because of like a lot of those narratives around love being like destined or like intertwined with fate and all of these
like very magical beautiful principles. But it takes away human agency sometimes and it takes away the sense that like, hey no, like I can actually, I actually have a say in this. I have a say in like how I want to be in this relationship, in this situation. And then there's another component of this that I think I really want to hear your opinion on, which is that we can know what healthy love should look like. But for some of us, for some of us, it can actually be quite uncomfortable. So even if we know that like healthy love should feel easy, healthy love should feel peaceful, it also sometimes feels boring.
And this is something that I hear all the time, which is, I feel like I found the one, but it feels boring. Or I'm worried about it becoming boring the longer I'm with this person. I'm worried that, like, I didn't have this really intense spark. There wasn't this chase. What does that mean for my relationship? Can you kind of, like, why do you think we confuse safe with boring? So many reasons. Well, one thing that's kind of unrelated to love, but I'm going to bring into this conversation right from the jump is if you think about TikTok or Instagram Reels, they've become so popular and so addicting in the last few years especially because you're scrolling and scrolling and scrolling and you don't know what you're going to get. Every new thing is, it's like you have this anticipation, right? And that's what dopamine is about. It's the molecule of anticipation.
So when you're in the thrill of the chase of like, oh, or even when you just meet someone new, even if it's really healthy, you're like, oh, are we going to kiss tonight for the first time? Like, where are we going to go to dinner next week? Like, oh, I'm just constantly thinking about them. And like, it's new. It's exciting. What am I going to learn about this person? So there's a lot of anticipation. And that's wonderful.
But eventually there becomes a point where it's not necessarily. needed to have so much anticipation when you become more committed to somebody because you know where they stand, you know where you stand, and that can be a beautiful thing. But then it does take away some of that anticipation. It takes away some of that dopamine. And unfortunately, there's kind of two opposite sides of the pendulum. I'm not sure if you've read Meeting in Captivity by Esther Perel or if you're familiar with it. But I absolutely love that book. And the concept she talks about is that passion and desire are on the opposite pendulum of comfort and safety. And it makes sense because one of them thrives off of uncertainty, mystery, newness,
and the other one thrives off of comfort and safety and reliability. And so as you have more reliability and more comfort, more emotional connection in your relationship, inevitably you're kind of moving away from that opposite and end of the desire, excitement, newness pendulum. And that doesn't mean you can't infuse that into your relationship. But if you want a relationship with stability and commitment, you're automatically taking away some of the mystery to begin with that unhealthy love has, which is that chase you mentioned, or sometimes they respond, sometimes they don't.
Or even if you're the one kind of running away from someone chasing you, like neither of those are fully committed people. It's kind of like this push-pull dynamic. Oh my goodness. So spot on. The pendulum that you just described, I think that is entirely accurate. And I like that you said it doesn't mean that you can't have those occasionally,
but it is almost, I hate to say that it's a choice, but there does come a point, I think, especially in our 20s, where we have to decide, do I want to keep pursuing these people? people that constantly make me feel anxious, even though that feels exciting. Do I want to constantly be around people where it's like, this is fun, not because I'm entertained,
but because I'm stressed. Like, we confuse, like, feelings of anxiety and excitement and passion and, like, actually just nervous arousal so often. And I do feel like, and I'm speaking from personal experience and from the experience of friends, you get to this point where you're like, okay, there is this group. of people who are going to make me feel this way, which is the excitement, the passion, and whatnot. And then there's this other group of people who will actually make me feel really calm and who will respect my boundaries. And they might not be my first choice. That doesn't
mean that they need to be completely counted out. Because if you're really thinking about like what you want in the future, if what you want is healthy love, that might not look how you thought it would, you know, like it might not look how you were sold it in the movie. and in TV shows and even by your parents and even by social media. Like, I feel like that also plays a massive role in what we come to expect from our partners. For sure. And I've had clients, and I understand exactly where they're coming from when they say this, but I've had people come to me and maybe they're just in one session or at the beginning of our time together.
And they're like, my partner liked me back right away. And they told me they liked me back right away. and part of me was like, why don't they have anyone else that they're like available talking to you? Or like, are they just lame or something? Like it's almost like we want the safe person. But then when the safe person is actually there and committed, we don't. And I think in theory it feels nice to be like, oh, this guy was dating around, but they chose me as if we win some kind of trophy. But if you actually hear how I just said that, it's like that's not actually.
necessarily something to look up to. It's just that you won something and you got to have an ego boost. But then when the safe, healthy person's available and telling you that they're into you, for some reason, that gives people the ick. Yeah, it gives me. It used to give me the ick a little bit. Because I think that it's like also very and like very patriarchal where it's like... That's true. You know what I mean? Where it's like women like you need to be pursued. you like it's not meant to be like easy you need to like tie him down and I know that's like a very like heteronormative way of looking at it but that does infuse it to think I think everyone's minds where it's like we have been sold like unrealistic relationship like trope that actually probably
won't make us happy but because we might not see a lot of other examples of that we only want this thing that like is unhealthy but looks really good it's kind of like I always give the analogy of the difference between like a really, really fulfilling, like, salad or a really, like, nutritional meal and, like, McDonald's or, like, or, like, something that's, like, super, like, high and saturated fat and sugary. I think that those relationships that feel really exciting and passionate and, like, euphoric and, like, intense, that is your, like, fast food right there. Like, that is going to make, that is just going to, like, set your taste buds.
It's going to set your brain on fire. It's going to be delicious. and then you're going to be left feeling sick, like, a couple hours later, and, like, it's not necessarily what's best for your body, even though it's what feels best in the moment. And then you have something like a really nutritious, like a nutritional, nutritious meal. And a nutritious meal is like, okay, yeah, maybe it's not as, like, exciting, but also you're going to feel healthier. You're going to live better, might even live longer. Like, you're going to just have a better sense of wellness.
And the same goes for relationships, especially those. in our 20s. So how can we kind of tell when the person we're dating isn't right for us? What are some of the warning signs of that like really electric individual who isn't leaving us feeling safe, but also might not be leaving us feeling bored? Yeah. Well, I think that what I talked about earlier with like that two-way street, you know, love being give and take, that feels really important. Where if you feel like it's kind of that whole what am I going to get from this person like oh sometimes they text me back in two hours and sometimes it takes three days you know that feels like it's going to be the more exciting thing because you're left on your toes but to me it feels really important to
have someone who is giving you their commitment or at least communicating hey I have a really busy week I'll check back in later that feels important and feeling like you can share your authentic self, not feeling like you're performing for that person. Because one of the reasons I believe that people, you know, in the honeymoon stage or whatever, they kind of have this like fantasy of a person. And one of the reasons I think they can slip over later to like, oh, I don't know if I like this person anymore is because you're both kind of putting this act on unintentionally, but you're like, I need to make sure that they think that I do this and this and this and this type person, which is, I'm sure some of who you are, but if you don't peel the curtain back on some of your vulnerable
self, then how are you going to know if they receive that and honor that in you? So I think even though it's scary to do, and maybe you don't do it in the first 10 minutes, but throughout getting to know somebody, can you show up as your more vulnerable self? And are you met with that? And one last thing is just kind of someone who creates a safe space for you to have feelings that aren't just positive vibes only. That feels really important, especially for anyone listening who may also have anxiety. It's like I'm not showing up perfectly all the time, but my partner is able to honor if I'm having feelings that aren't positive, quote, and help support me. I put this thing on my Instagram the other day that was like,
how did you know when the person you're dating was the one, or the person that you are married to was the one? And that was one of the biggest things that people said was they honored both the positive sides of me and the, like, I don't want to say negative, but like the ugliest sides of me, the sides of me that I would prefer to hide. Like it is that, like, true acceptance that is, like, the most beautiful thing about love.
but you also made a really good point about the honeymoon phase. I, when I first started dating my partner, was terrified of the honeymoon phase ending. Because I think I'd spent a lot of my 20s loving the initial stages of a relationship, right? Like, it's so fun. It's so fun when, like, you really don't know anything about someone and, like, everything they're doing is, like, surprising you
and they're really trying to win you over. like you said, maybe even putting up like a bit of a facade, like a bit of a false persona. When the honeymoon period ends, how can we identify whether it is just the end of like the beginnings of the relationship or whether some of the feelings that we're associating with the end of the honeymoon phase is really like a sign that maybe this is the wrong relationship for us. Like does that make sense? Like is it just the honeymoon phase? or is the relationship actually doomed? Yeah, definitely.
I think if your whole relationship is based off of feelings alone, then that's where it could be the beginning of the end. If you're only relying on your feelings, because feelings are going to come and go and you use this beautiful word autonomy earlier, like taking away our human autonomy of choosing, if you are only in a relationship because it's destined and your soulmates, then there's no choice, there's no intention.
intentionality. There's no showing up and building and creating a beautiful love. And so I think that if someone, the feelings completely fade and you're looking across at the other person, you're like, wait, we have nothing in common. We don't have any shared goals for life. We don't accept and respect who this person is sitting across from each other, then that doesn't feel like the foundations of a healthy relationship moving forward. Whereas if you have a lot of shared values, if you, accept the differences of this person. If you feel like you can at least be moving on parallel paths, like, in similar directions, you don't have to completely intertwine and do everything in your life together.
But if you're doing your thing and they're doing theirs and then you have your thing together, do you feel like that's moving in a direction that you can be excited about, right? And even though the future's out of your hands, does it feel like an exciting notion? And to me, that's really important. And I don't think that that's the sexy thing of like, oh, our values are aligned. Yay. But the acceptance and the respect of who this person is, that feels really big. And so when the feelings fade, if you don't have that, like, I don't know if that is a great jumping off point, to be fair.
Yeah. And what are you even going to talk about? Yeah. Like, if you're not, you know, if you don't have the feelings and you don't have like the values or like the future, it's, kind of, I think it's very hard to stay in that place. The other beautiful thing that someone told me the other day, which really lessened my fear of the honeymoon phase ending. And it's similar to what you were just talking about is think about all the versions of this person that you are yet to meet. And all the versions that you are going to get to fall in love with in the
future. And me and my partner do this all the time where we're like, oh, you know what version of me? Like, you haven't met yet. Like, you haven't met like the version. of me that's going to be like a father. You haven't met like the version of me that's going to be like retired. You haven't met the version of me that's going to be like, it's going to be in Paris next year. Like you know what I mean? It's like you did not just fall in, I don't think you've just fallen in love with one person. You fall in love with many versions of that one person that you will like continue to see over your life together if that's something that you want. I don't know. It always just brings me so much peace thinking about that. That's so beautiful.
未来。我和我的伴侣经常这样，我们会说，噢，你知道吗，我身上有一个你还没见过的版本。比如，你还没见过我当父亲的那个版本。你还没见过我退休以后的那个版本。你还没见过我明年要去巴黎的那个版本。你知道我的意思吗？这就好像你并非只是陷入，我不认为你只是爱上了一个人。你是爱上了同一个人身上的许多不同版本，只要你愿意，在你们共度人生的过程中，你会不断看到这些版本。我不知道。每次想到这一点，我的内心就会感到无比平静。这真是太美妙了。
And it's so open-minded and open-hearted compared to what sometimes happens is like we have this exact view of the perfect partner. They need to be exactly this and they need to stay exactly like this or they're changing when what you just shared is like this. It's just this like room for possibilities and knowing that you're going to evolve just like they will too. And that you get to have many different chapters in your book. It doesn't have to just stay the same page repeating forever. It's so true. And that's like the thing, when you stay in relationships that make you feel passionate and, like, excited, that is the same chapter just repeating over and over again. You know what I mean? That is where you actually stop growing because you are really just addicted
而且与我们有时抱有的那种死板观念相比，这非常开明，也非常敞开心扉。我们有时会觉得完美伴侣必须拥有某种确切的模样，他们必须完全是这样，并且必须一直保持这样，否则就是变了。而你刚才分享的观点则留下了无限可能，让你明白你会不断进化，他们也一样。你的生命之书将拥有许多不同的篇章，而不必永远重复同一页。确实如此。这就是问题所在，当你停留在那些让你感到充满激情和兴奋的关系中时，其实就是在不断重复同一章。你知道我的意思吗？正是在这种状态下，你实际上停止了成长，因为你真正沉迷的
to a feeling rather than to, like, a person and rather than to your growth and rather than to something that is, like, has longevity. Like, someone said this to me, like, asked me the other day, like, is love, is it just chemical? And to some extent, I do think that, like, the early stages of love really are. And that's why it's so addictive and so bonding. But it doesn't mean that that can't transform into something that is more, I don't know, everlasting and not just based on, like, a series of neurotransmitters that spike and decline and whatnot. Totally. And there's been research on the difference between what they call passionate love, which is about like dopamine firing
是一种感觉，而不是一个人，也不是你的成长，更不是某种持久的东西。比如，前几天有人对我说，问我，爱仅仅是化学反应吗？在某种程度上，我的确认为爱的早期阶段确实如此。这也是为什么它如此让人上瘾、如此具有黏合剂的作用。但这并不意味着它不能转化为更持久的东西，而不仅仅是一系列神经递质的激增、下降之类的事情。完全同意。关于人们所说的激情之爱的研究表明，激情之爱关乎多巴胺的分泌，
and then there's eventually this shift into more companion at love which has more of like the feel good chemicals like serotonin oxytocin and it doesn't mean that like you can't again infuse passion into a companion at love but the companion at love isn't just based off the feelings alone it's based off of a shared connection and showing up for one another and creating that love together versus just kind of like waiting for it to fall into your lap every morning Once again, the agency, the autonomy. Our two favorite words for this episode.
最终这种爱会转变为伴侣之爱，其中包含更多让人感觉良好的化学物质，比如血清素、催产素。这并不是说你不能再次将激情注入伴侣之爱中，而是伴侣之爱不仅仅建立在单纯的感觉之上，它建立在共同的连接、守望相助以及共同创造这种爱之上，而不是每天早上坐在那里等待爱情从天而降。再说一次，主动性、自主权，是我们这期播客最喜欢的两个词。
So, say there's someone listening to this who is like, all right, I'm like a year into my relationship. I'm a couple years in. And I feel like things are slowing down. Or they've just started dating someone and they're like, this is my first time experiencing healthy love. I'm constantly worried when it's going to end. I'm worried when the tables are going to turn. What are some of the ways that you think we can challenge those instances of relationship anxiety where, like you mentioned before, it may not actually be a problem you're just experiencing
所以，假设有人在听这期节目，心想：“好吧，我的恋爱关系大概有一年了，或者好几年了，我感觉事情正在放慢脚步。”或者他们刚开始约会某人，心里想：“这是我第一次体验到健康的爱，我总是担心它什么时候会结束，担心局势什么时候会逆转。”你认为我们可以通过哪些方式来挑战那些关系焦虑的时刻？就像你之前提到的，这可能根本不是什么问题，你只是在经历
that hypervigilance and that false alarm? Yeah, absolutely. Well, one thing that has been really helpful for me is to practice compassion for the general experience of relationship anxiety. So, like, as a whole, finding compassion for the fact that I have found love to be somewhat intimidating or somewhat scary, like, giving it a new meaning that this isn't something horrible that's happened to me. It's more like, this is something that I really care about and I really value.
那种过度警惕和虚假警报？是的，绝对的。对我来说非常有帮助的一个方法是，对这种普遍的关系焦虑体验保持同情。也就是说，总体而言，理解并同情我发现爱有时有点吓人或有点可怕这一事实，赋予它一个新的含义：这不是发生在我身上的可怕事情，而是我真正关心、真正珍视的东西。
And so it does scare me sometimes to think about it, not working out or whatever it is. Like, that needs to be there versus the judgment. and the criticism for experiencing that. And then also in those micro moments, too, if you have a trigger pop up, or maybe because your walls came up, you kind of said something critical to your partner when you really actually were craving connection,
因此，想到它可能会搞砸或者诸如此类的事情，有时确实会让我感到害怕。我们需要接纳这种情绪，而不是去评判和批判自己为什么会有这种体验。然后在那些微小的时刻里，如果你被某个触发点击中，或者可能因为你筑起了心防，对伴侣说了一些带有批判性的话，而你内心其实非常渴望连接，
but your anxiety came up and led you to kind of push them away in some way. Instead of letting that shame spiral go on for hours or days, just acknowledging that was a moment of anxiety. It wasn't my best, but how can I take one next act? towards love, towards reconnection, and that can be loving yourself or loving the partner. But I think so often we just beat ourselves up for this experience. And then not only do we stay disconnected from our relationship, but it's just really critical up in our brain too.
但你的焦虑情绪涌现出来，导致你把对方推开了。与其让这种羞耻感的漩涡持续数小时或数天，不如承认这只是一个焦虑的时刻。虽然不是我最好的表现，但我该如何迈出走向爱、走向重新连接的下一步呢？这可以是对自己的爱，也可以是对伴侣的爱。但我认为，我们往往会因为这种体验而过度苛责自己。这样一来，我们不仅与伴侣的关系疏远了，而且大脑也陷入了极度批判的状态。
And I don't think that you can shame yourself out of past trauma. Like you cannot, or bad habits. Like you cannot shame yourself out of any of those things. I just think that it just actually ends up exacerbating it because you feel less like emotionally in control. You feel like your emotions are less valid. I really love that tip. The other one I would say is, and I'm sure you talk about this a lot as well,
我不认为你能通过感到羞耻来摆脱过去的创伤。就像你无法，或者坏习惯。你无法通过自我羞耻来摆脱任何这些东西。我只是觉得这最终只会加剧焦虑，因为你会觉得自己在情绪上的掌控力更弱了，会觉得自己的情绪不那么合理。我真的很喜欢这个建议。我要说的另一个建议是，我确信你们也经常讨论这一点，
actually take time to understand where, like what the trigger is, like you said. Like really break it down and be like, okay, I can really, identify that this came from the fact that in my previous relationship, you know, my partner used to pull away from me as soon as I was, when I did something that he perceived as wrong. Or he would like give and take affection like it was like a tool for control. And so this person maybe just actually setting a healthy boundary with me and being like, oh, I've got to work late. sorry, that is triggering because it, like, it feels like a repeat of a past situation. And actually just tell them, like, just tell your partner that that's what you're feeling.
那就是花时间去理解触发点在哪里，正如你所说的那样。真正去剖析它，然后说：“好的，我能清楚地识别出，这源于我上一段感情中，每当我做了他认为不对的事情时，我的伴侣就会立刻疏离我。或者他会把施舍和收回关爱当作控制的工具。”所以，当这个人可能只是在对我和谐地设定界限，说“噢，我要加班，抱歉”时，这触发了我的焦虑，因为它感觉像是过去情境的重演。而你实际上只需告诉他们，把你的真实感受告诉你的伴侣。
I had to do this recently. And it was, like, it was hard to be like, oh, this is why. But as soon as, like, that was made known, it made a lot of sense, more sense to both of us and actually made it a lot healthier. Absolutely. I love that one. And if I may add one more into the mix too. Sometimes anxiety can just be this big cluttered mess in the mind and we try to think our way out.
我最近就不得不这样做。当时感觉很难说出口：“噢，这就是原因所在。”但一旦把这件事挑明，我们俩都觉得事情变得更好理解了，这段关系也因此变得健康得多。绝对的。我很喜欢这个建议。如果我还可以再补充一点的话。有时焦虑只是大脑中一团杂乱无章的乱麻，而我们总是试图通过思考来摆脱它。
So are they the one? How can I be sure? Let me Google this. It just becomes this like upward spiral almost like this dust of so much potential outcomes. It gets really hard to actually figure that out. So if you're feeling overwhelmed in that moment, what you just said is a perfect thing to do. maybe if you're like, if you've gotten a little bit more grounded, you're like, okay, let me dissect this trigger a bit so I can have that awareness. But if you're just like in the thick of it,
所以，他们是那个对的人吗？我怎么才能确信？让我去谷歌一下。这最终会变成一场向上的精神漩涡，就像无数可能结果激起的尘埃，让人很难真正搞清楚状况。因此，如果你在那一刻感到不知所措，你刚才所说的方法就是完美的做法。也许等你稍微平静下来之后，你会想：“好吧，让我剖析一下这个触发点，好让我能有所觉察。”但如果你正深陷其中，
one thing I found is really important is to bring the body in some way and remind yourself that in the present moment, you are safe. So unless you are physically unsafe and something's actually happening to you in that moment, your brain and body are signaling danger, but there isn't necessarily danger. So maybe your partner just said something kind of weird and then you're firing off like, oh gosh, like I don't know if I could be with someone like that and then it feels really scary inside, but taking some deep breaths or using your five senses to come back to the space around you where you are and taking some time to get grounded and remembering like I'm physically safe in this moment. I'm sitting across from my partner or I'm on the couch with my partner.
我发现非常重要的一点是，以某种方式让身体参与进来，提醒自己在当下你是安全的。除非你正处于身体不安全的状态，且当时确实有事情正在发生，否则你的大脑和身体虽然在发出危险信号，但并不一定真的存在危险。所以，也许你的伴侣只是说了一些有点奇怪的话，然后你脑海中就开始疯狂运转：“噢天哪，我不知道我能不能和这样的人在一起，”这时候内心会觉得非常害怕。但你可以通过做几次深呼吸，或者利用五官感知来回到你身处周围的空间，花点时间让自己安定下来，记住：此刻我在生理上是安全的，我正坐在伴侣对面，或者我和伴侣一起坐在沙发上。
like I'm not actually in danger here because we think we are. And then it can feel like we need to solve the danger or fix the danger right away versus getting a little bit of space from it. Yeah, I love that. I'm sorry, but when you said we think that we can, what outthink anxiety? Is that what you said? Like something like that. Oh, my goodness.
我其实并没有处于危险之中，尽管我们以为自己身处危险。然后我们就会觉得我们需要立刻解决危险或消除危险，而不是与它保持一点空间。是的，我太喜欢这个观点了。对不起，但刚才你说我们以为我们可以怎么着？过度思考来摆脱焦虑？你是这么说的吗？诸如此类的话。噢，天哪！
I'm like, wow, that is so true. If we think about it more, suddenly we're going to find this a little. but it really just makes us more anxious. That is like a real slap in the face for me. I'm like real call out. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available.
我想，哇，这太对了！如果我们想得越多，突然之间我们就会发现……但这只会让我们更焦虑。这对我来说真是一记当头棒喝，感觉被狠狠点名了。2%！这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，依然选择走楼梯的人的比例。
I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%, I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts. and more to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory.
我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析在当今这个奇妙的现代世界中，如何培养精神韧性、强健体魄以及建立复原力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康与健身专家展开对话。深入探讨并看清那些充斥在健康产业中的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们曾经真的深信种子油生来就会引起炎症。
We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tap Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking.
我们错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题，其实都是压力的结果。经历一些艰难险阻，你最终会迎来一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的自己。请收听《2%》。这就是数字 2，可在 IHeart Radio 应用程序、苹果播客或您获取播客的任何地方收听。你还记得当戴安娜·罗斯在 VMA 颁奖典礼上拍打小姬姆的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不关心黑人时？我知道你在想什么。
What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 was big to me, not just because of crack.
乔治·布什跟小姬姆到底有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《Look Back at It》播客中找到答案。我是山姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。在每一期节目中，我们都会挑选一个事件，剖析当时发生了什么，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。包括最近一期节目中，马克·拉蒙特·hill大谈80年代的快克可卡因。坦白说，84年对我很重要，不仅仅是因为快克。
I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack, so I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now, so... Thank you for finishing that sentence. Yes, I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah.
我随时都可以聊当年的快克，只是想让你们知道我的意思。我是说，马克，到目前为止，这是我们讨论快克的第二期节目了，所以我开始看出这里面有一条贯穿始终的主线了。我们现在甚至还把艾滋病也摆上台面了，所以……谢谢你把这句话说完。是的，我不认为对黑人来说还有比这更重要的年份了。真的吗？是的。
For me, it's one of the most important years. for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hardway with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience
对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的年份之一。欢迎在 IHeart Radio 应用程序、苹果播客或您获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at It》。欢迎收看我的新播客《硬核学习》，我是主持人、也是你们最喜爱的治疗师吉尔·盖恩斯。为了庆祝心理健康意识月，我带来了我自己在心理健康领域十多年的经验，
in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing and we're still chasing it and we don't know when we've done enough because people scoreboard watch life becomes about wins and losses Steve Burns Dustin Ross because you find it important to be a good person while you
以及与许多不可思议的嘉宾的对话。我说的是特里普·方丹、瑞安·克拉克。有时我们在追求某事时，会过于沉迷于追逐的过程，以至于没有意识到我们其实已经拥有了它，却还在继续追逐，甚至不知道什么时候才算足够，因为人们都在盯着记分牌，生活变成了一场胜负游戏。史蒂夫·伯恩斯、达斯汀·罗斯，因为你觉得在世期间做一个好人很重要，
hear on earth or are you a good person because you're afraid because that's two different intentions bro absolutely and that that's two different levels of trust I want you to just really be a good person join me Kear gains is we have real conversations about healing growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway. Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth.
还是说你成为一个好人只是因为你感到害怕？因为这是两种完全不同的动机，兄弟。绝对的，这是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你能真正地做一个好人。加入我的播客《硬核学习》，我们将一起探讨关于疗愈、成长、父爱、压力和使命的真实对话。打开免费的 iHeartRadio 应用程序。搜索《Learn the Hardway》并立即收听。2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德发现自己卷入了一场亲子鉴定丑闻。随后的家庭法庭听证会揭露了他故事中明显的矛盾之处。由此开启了一场长达数年的法律之战，以证明真相。
You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. L.S. Correct? I doctored the test one. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Gregalespian and Michael Marantini.
L.S.女士，你曾两次篡改这份特定的测试报告，对吗？我篡改了一次测试。这需要一支由网络侦探组成的队伍来破解这个案件。我希望人们能看到他们的纳税都被用在了什么地方。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们揭露了一种令人不安的模式。还有另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格·莱斯皮安和迈克尔·马拉蒂尼。
My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news. at Ameriopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona.
我的大脑彻底炸裂了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《爱情陷阱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的推进，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。女士们先生们，突发新闻。马里科帕县宣布劳拉·欧文斯已被起诉欺诈罪。在亚利桑那州，正义得到伸张之前，这一切都不会结束。
Listen to Love Trapped Podcast on the Iheart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. I have one final question for you, which is, what do we do when we feel bored? When our relationship does feel a little bit boring, how can we shift that up, change that up? So I would say two key things here. The first one might be surprising because I'm not going to start within the relationship. I'm going to start within yourself because sometimes we get into a relationship and we stop doing the things that light us up that make us feel excited. Our creativity, our time with our friends, our travel, our learning new things, the things that make us feel like we have exciting things in our life. and if you're not doing that, then you're going to also project the boredom you feel in your life onto the relationship. Because we've been sold this idea that once you find the one
请在 Iheart Radio 应用程序、苹果播客或任何你获取播客的地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。我有一个最后的问题想问你，那就是：当我们感到无聊时该怎么办？当我们的恋爱关系确实显得有点枯燥时，我们该如何扭转局面、改变现状？我想说这里有两个关键点。第一点可能会让你感到意外，因为我不会从恋爱关系本身开始切入。我将从你自己开始，因为有时我们进入一段恋爱关系后，就会停止做那些能点燃我们、让我们感到兴奋的事情。比如我们的创造力、和朋友相处的时间、旅行、学习新事物，以及那些让我们觉得生活中充满兴奋的事情。如果你没有做这些，那么你就会把生活中感受到的无聊投射到恋爱关系上。因为我们一直被灌输这样一种观念：一旦你找到了真爱，
or once you find a partner, then all your problems are solved and you just ride off into the sunset and like they kind of make you complete or make you whole. But I want people listening to check in with themselves of, has my relationship gotten boring or have I all? also gotten boring and that contributes to how my relationship is feeling. That's the first component. And the second component is bringing some of that anticipation or newness back into the relationship. So trying new things together, whether that's a new restaurant, a new trip, a new day trip, a new
或者一旦你找到了伴侣，你所有的烦恼就都解决了，你们就会一起骑马走向日落，他们会让你的人生变得完整。但我希望听节目的每个人都自我审视一下：究竟是我的恋爱关系变得无聊了，还是我也变得无聊了，而这正是导致我当前恋爱感受的原因？这是第一部分。第二部分是将期待感或新鲜感重新带回恋爱关系中。一起尝试新鲜事物，无论是去一家新餐厅、来一次新旅行、一次新的日间短途旅行、一个新
new hobby, a new activity, even like asking your partner what's something you've always wanted to do and maybe you don't love it, but you still try it for them. And then you don't, do something that you love. It could be like physically like with intimacy to like just I don't know spice things up a bit. Like I feel like we get into these very conditional like routines where we're just like, all right, this is working. So let's keep it going. This feels safe like we've talked about. But then eventually we need that uncertainty back. We need that mystery. And we have to be responsible for creating it. Oh my goodness. We have to be responsible for creating our own mystery. Very, very true. I honestly completely agree with you. And the hobby thing is really important.
的新爱好、一项新活动，甚至可以问问你的伴侣：“你一直想做的一件事是什么？”也许你并不那么喜欢它，但你仍然愿意为了对方去尝试。然后不去做那些你只喜欢自己的事。这甚至可以体现在亲密关系的物理层面，去……我不知道，给生活加点料。我觉得我们很容易陷入这种非常习以为常的常规中，以至于我们只会说：“好吧，这套方法管用，那就继续保持吧。这感觉很安全，”就像我们之前讨论的那样。但最终，我们需要那种不确定性回归，我们需要神秘感。而且我们必须为创造这种神秘感负责。噢，天哪！我们必须为创造属于我们自己的神秘感负责。真的，真的太对了。老实说，我完全赞同你的观点。培养爱好真的很重要。
And also the friendships, I think that when we start dating someone, they become like the new center of our like social orbit and like our social universe. And it causes like everyone else to be pushed out a little bit. And I think that's natural because they are, they do require like a huge investment of time and energy to get the relationship to a point where it is like a true love. But sometimes I think we get like six months in and we look around and we're like, oh, okay, we need to recalibrate here and like bring some of those other important plays in my life back into the equation. So I want to say, thank you so much for coming on, Sarah. I actually feel like this was selfishly just free therapy for me. I'm like, just listening to you being like, yeah,
还有友情也是。我认为当我们开始与某人约会时，他们往往会成为我们社交轨道和社交宇宙的新中心。这会导致其他所有人被稍微疏远一点。我认为这是很自然的，因为他们确实需要投入大量的时间和精力，才能让这段关系发展到真爱的那一步。但有时我想，当关系进行到大约六个月时，我们环顾四周，会觉得：“噢，好吧，我们需要在这里重新校准一下，把生活中其他一些重要的人重新纳入生活方程中。”所以我想说，非常感谢你做客节目，萨拉。老实说，我感觉这简直是为我提供的免费私人治疗。我听着你的话直点头：
all right, let me write that down, like check. So I really do appreciate all your knowledge. and your opinions and just your value. Where can the listeners find you to learn more? Yeah, thank you so much. I receive those kind words and I love this conversation as well. And people can find me at You Love and You Learn both on Instagram and TikTok. And then I have a podcast as well, the You Love and You Learn podcast, which is much more focused on like relationship anxiety themes.
“好的，让我记下来，搞定。”我真的非常感谢你分享的知识、观点和价值。听众们可以在哪里找到你以了解更多信息呢？是的，非常感谢。我欣然接受这些暖心的赞美，我也非常喜欢今天的对话。大家可以在 Instagram 和 TikTok 上通过“You Love and You Learn”找到我。我还有一个播客，叫做“You Love and You Learn podcast”，这个播客更加专注于恋爱焦虑主题。
So I love your podcast, how it goes. like wide with so many amazing topics and mine is very kind of narrowed in on love and relationships so if that's people's jam then I'd love to have you come over and take a peek absolutely and actually I have listened to some of your episodes when I've been in like a little bit of like a relationship brought and they are super super helpful so I really do recommend if this episode really like resonated with you in any sense please go and see what Sarah is creating it's very very beautiful as always if you enjoyed this episode, please feel free to share it with a friend who needs to hear it, leave a
我非常喜欢你的播客，内容涉及面很广，有那么多精彩的话题，而我的播客则非常专注于爱与恋爱关系。所以如果这是大家感兴趣的方向，我很乐意邀请大家过来看看。绝对的，事实上，当我也陷入某种恋爱倦怠期时，我确实听过你的一些节目，它们真的超级超级有用。所以我真心推荐，如果这期节目在任何方面都引发了你的共鸣，请去看看萨拉创作的内容，真的非常非常棒。一如既往，如果你喜欢这期节目，请随时把它分享给需要它的朋友，留下一个
five-star review, and make sure that you're following along so you know when new episodes come out live. Additionally, if you have an episode suggestion or something that you would like us to talk about, please shoot me a DM, shoot me a message at That Psychology Podcast and follow us over there to see all of the behind-the-scenes content. We will be back next week with another episode. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host, Kare Games. This space is about black men's experiences,
五星好评，并确保关注我们的频道，这样你就不会错过新节目的更新。另外，如果你有什么节目建议或希望我们讨论的话题，请随时给我发私信，在《That Psychology Podcast》账号上联系我，并关注我们以获取所有幕后花絮内容。我们下周将带着另一期节目回归。嘿，最近怎么样，各位？欢迎收听《Learn the Hardway》，我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人吉尔·盖恩斯。这个空间专注于黑人男性的经历，
having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor? It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to Learn the Hardway on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast. or wherever you get your podcast.
进行一些在其他地方绝对不安全的坦诚对话，而你是在和一个懂得如何应对的持证专业人士进行交流。有多少男人披着一身铠甲？它向世界释放的信号是：你惹不起。仅仅因为你拥有这种能力，并不意味着你需要去使用它。欢迎在 AHA 广播应用程序、苹果播客或您获取播客的任何地方收听《Learn the Hardway》。
In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins, but the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice in selling, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing.
2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的生父，但这场怀孕似乎是一场骗局。L.S.女士，你曾两次篡改这份特定的测试报告，对吗？我篡改了一次测试。这需要一支由网络侦探组成的队伍来破解这个案件。他们揭露了一种令人不安的模式。还有另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。
Greg, a lesbian, Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is love trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available.
格雷格·莱斯皮安、迈克尔·曼奇尼。我的大脑彻底炸裂了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《爱情陷阱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的推进，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。请在 IHeart Radio 应用程序、苹果播客或任何你获取播客的地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。2%！这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，依然选择走楼梯的人的比例。
I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships. and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO%.
我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析在当今这个奇妙的现代世界中，如何培养精神韧性、强健体魄以及建立复原力的科学。经历一些艰难险阻，你最终会迎来一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的自己。请收听《2%》。这就是数字 2%。
On the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves.
可在 IHeartRadio 应用程序、苹果播客或您获取播客的任何地方收听。当一群女性发现她们约会的竟然是同一个高产骗子时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓，我将成为他最后一个目标。他休想就这么逃脱。他罪有应得。
We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the IHeart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们总是说，相信你的好姐妹。请在 IHeart radio 应用程序、苹果播客或您获取播客的任何地方收听《The Girlfriends: Trust Me, Babe》。这是一档 IHeart 播客。品质真人保证。本期节目暂无评论。点击转写中的任意句子即可留下评论。